oh my god I missed the chair hey guys
what's up
that was my impression of all youtubers
looking at their own face in the pop-out
screen I do it - welcome to pray diary
for divers I look back in my week and
vlog form this week right now I am in a
hotel a hotel right now I am in a hotel
in London England ever heard of it
google it it's a place but my week
didn't start out this way so let's look
back in my wake guys I'm at my mom's
house with my matching sweater look her
hey do you want to tell them what we're
about to do we're about to dad to get
this matching sweater
what are we about to do where we're
going we're going to our cars on the way
taking it to the airport and we are
packed we think we're gonna find out
it's gonna be it's gonna be a whirlwind
these two dum-dums try to handle London
dumb and tweedle day oh here we go
did you bring these guys Oh what do you
like go so great otherwise you think
they'll work this is what I haven't used
this camera to vlog oh yes they will
work what are they
mom started working
good morning it's day two of grace and
mom take London
hey Phil mom good yeah yeah you got your
London scarf on today I like it I need
something yeah it's really cold today
yeah we walked five miles yesterday and
today maybe we'll probably do that about
the same as like so let's fuel up
there's a reenactment happening yes
acting
I do not understand what's happening are
you enjoying this oh I am thoroughly and
just me and them what's happening right
now I don't know
Oh what did your makeup you look so
beautiful I have a makeup artist I do
morning good morning it's day 3 we are
going to see the change in the guard
after we fix how crooked sunglasses are
look we a coffee month coffee she's
eating a croissant I'm wearing a blazer
how goddamn European are we right now
design a sweatshirt representing the
United States the only way she knows how
also I don't think I fully explained
this I brought my mom to London as a
birthday present / just long time
conversation about wanting to do this
together and it's been really really fun
also do you ever wonder what Barbie
looks like on the inside well there you
go there has been a look back in my week
it has been so amazing my mom and I are
here for a couple more days and then we
head back to the states as they refer to
it here in London also just so you guys
know I am nominated for a Teen Choice
Award for choice web star female and
it's up to you guys to vote so if you
want to you can go to vote that teen
choice calm and vote for me if you live
in the United States if you don't live
in the United States apparently so I've
heard
don't know how true this is but hey
let's try it you can tweet Instagram and
Facebook
hashtag choice web star female grace
Helbig and they count that as votes how
I have no idea but you can vote up to
three times a day and you can vote every
day so please go nuts be whirling
dervishes of votes everywhere I would
love that so so much can you imagine a
29 year old winning a Teen Choice Award
that should be illegal and as an
incentive if you guys vote for me and I
do win I really truly promise to deliver
a very entertaining speech it's one of
my special skills
yeah meow-meow and but thank you most
importantly - god I love that guy
second of all thank you to Jesus okay
thank you guys for watching don't forget
to subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already because clearly you need
it in your life I've been watching a lot
of younger youtubers lately and they
seem to love to open-ended lis question
you guys with a task of getting the
video to a certain number of likes hey
guys do you think we'll get this video
to 23,000 likes if we do doesn't really
mean anything but I've certain my power
for you that said hey guys can we get
this video to 57,000 likes if you do I
will continue to make videos uh I got
stopped I don't know
um well hair hey let's join the rest of
the party okay hey hey yeah look how
much fun you have when you socialize
with each other there we go